[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم
اليوم هو رئيس وزاره سابق لباكستان عمران
خان ومعان
كنت رئيسا للوزراء لمده ثلاثه سنوات ونصف
الاجهزه الاستخباراتيه عملت تحت امرتي
وبالتالي اعرف كيف تعمل هذه الاجهزه واعرف
تماما ما حدث وكنت قد توقعت هكذا حادث
مسبقا قبل تقريبا سته اسابيع عندما تم
اتهامي بالتجديف في شريط فيديو
باسم الحكومه وكذلك تلفزيون
وان كل من رئيس الوزراء وزير الداخليه
قتل 12 شخصا رميه بالرصاص وجرح 60 اخرون
نحن نعرف تاريخهم وبالتالي وفي حال اجراء
تحقيق المستقبل
فسيتبينوا بانه هؤلاء الثلاثه هم وراء هذه
الاعتداء الدعاء بان المهاجم هو متواريخ
دينيا ولكن في الواقع هو ليس بشخص متدين
اصلا وخلفيتهم معروفه
وتحدث عنها الصحافيون اذا كل هذا مفبرك
من رئيس المحكمه العليا بطريقه رسم
هذا بالضبط صحيح
هناك ادعاء بوجود مسلح واحد فقط متعصب
دينيا هو الذي اطلق النار عليه ولكن نعرف
بانه كان هناك مسلح ثاني في الامان واعرف
ان اي تحقيق مستقل سيثبت ما اقول اي انها
كانت محاوله اغتيال مدبره ضدي والمستفيد
الاول هو هذه الحكومه لانه منذ اخراجي من
السلطه تعضنت شعبيه حسبي وفزنا بنسبه 75%
من الانتخابات الجزئيه لقد اصيبوا بالذعر
ازاء امكانيه فوزنا في الانتخابات القادمه
ولذلك قرروا تصفيته
بروبلم
تقوله السؤال هو هل رئيس المحكمه سيتمكن
بالقيام بتحقيق من هذا القبيل انت تتحدث
عن الضغوط التي تمارست عليه من قبل
الحكومه والجيش سيكون هناك تحقيق مستقل
ان وكالات واجهزه التحقيق
الثلاثه
الاستخبارات وبالتالي لا يمكنها ان تجلس
تحقيقا حقيقيا تحت اشرافهم
لذا طلبته من رئيس المحكمه العليا
من الاقسام والاجهزه الاستخباراتيه
المختلفه وهذه هي الطريقه الوحيده التي
نامل من خلالها ان تتحقق العداله
همم جاستس
بالسكان همم فيو
اسابيع قبل هذا الهجوم بالدكه
بطريقه
الاستخبارات الباكستانيه او اي عضو من
اعضاءها ان يعقد ذلك المؤتمر الصحفي لانني
لو قمت بالرد على كل نقطه منه
ما لا اريده لاننا بحاجه الى جيش قويه
اعتقد بان ذلك المؤتمر الصحفي جاء ردا على
ما حدث لاحد افضل الصحفيين الاستقصائيين
الذي عبر عن وجهه نظري
فتلقى تهديدات بالقتل ثم غادر البلاد وقد
تم اغتياله في كينيا مما اثار جدلا وسقبا
شعبيه
لذا شعرت بان ذلك المؤتمر الصحفي كان
بالاحرى لتهدئه الراي العام
برايد اه
اجان همم
يمكننا ان نتصور بانك عززت امنك
وهل تشعر بانك مهدد مره اخرى بالاغتيال هل
ما لم يصل الى النتيجه في البدايه سيصل
لان نتيجه في المستقبل
هؤلاء الاشخاص الذين ارادوا تصفيه لاسباب
الاكثر شعبيه
ديسبايدر
75% من الانتخابات الجزئيه وذلك رغما عن
الحزب الحاكم والاحزاب الاخرى كلها معا
والمدعومه من المؤسسات الرسميه رغم ذلك
كله فزنا في الانتخابات النصفيه وزادت
شعبيتنا
فالناس لم يعد يريدون ان يحكمها هؤلاء
المجرمون
61% من الحكومه الحاليه متهمون في قضايا
فساد ولذلك احظى بهذا الدعم الجماهير
الكبير لذلك هم يعتقدون بان الطريقه
الوحيده لابعادي هي اغتيالي وبالتالي
يعتقدوا بان التهديد على حياته ما زال
قائما همم
انصارك استئناف المظاهرات الكبرى
العاصمه
بانك ستنضمه الى هذه المباراه
اللهم امين
وفي عقيدتنا نقول ان ارواح بيد الله عز
وجل
اننا نحتاج وسنحتاج بشكل اكبر في المستقبل
ولكن
سياده القانون في هذا البلد وهذه هي
مشكلتنا الكبرى
فوق القانون السياسيون يعملون فوق القانون
وهذا هو السبب في عدم ازدهار البلاد قبل
26 عاما في حركه من اجل العداله وسياده
القانون
لن يمنعني من مواصله هذه المهمه
حرب الاهليه
انا اعمل في ميدان السياسه منذ 26 عاما
عملته دائما في اطار الدستوري والدستور
يعطي الحق في التظاهر سلميا مظاهراتنا
كانت دائما سلميه وهذه المسيره ستكون في
اطار ما يسمح به الدستور
حاليا في باكستان حيث يستولي مجموعه من
التماسيح على
البلاد
61%
اصبحت اليوم
بلدنا ازمه اقتصاديه
نخرج من هذه الازمه عبر انتخابات حره
انتظر ماردتوش الانتخابات بعد شهر او سنه
وفي جامع الاحوال علينا الانتظار
والمشاركه ولا يحظى اي حزب اخر من الدعم
الذي يحظى به حزبنا الان ولكن الفكره هي
انه لا يمكن ان يستمر بلدنا على هذه
الحالتين
اتهمت الولايات المتحده بالعمل
هل هذا دليل على انه ليس لك دليل بشان هذه
الاتهامات او انك كما يقول اعداؤك ابتكرت
المؤامره
حسنا في الواقع كانت هناك برقيه
مسجله
حول محادثات سريه بين سفيرنا في واشنطن
ومساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي دونالد لو
فيها
عمران
في السنه التاليه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان ادعي هذا
الامر يقف عائقا امام مصلحه الشعب
الباكستانيه هذه المصلحه التي تتمثل
بعلاقات جيده مع جميع البلدان ولاسيم
الولايات المتحده بكونها قوه عظمى هذا ما
قلته ولم اتراجع عن تصريحات هذه البرقيه
موجوده
وعرضت على الحكومه وعلى مجلس الامن القومي
وهي الان لدى رئيس المحكمه العليا الذي
طلبنا منه اجراء تحقيق مستقل والامر لا
يتعلق ابدا بالتراجع عن كلامي
من الباكستان وشكرا لكم على متابعه هذا
الحوار
[موسيقى]